have you seen a beautiful mind that  movie years ago well what do you think  about the game theoretic formulation of  uh what is it the hot blonde at the bar  do you remember like oh yeah the way  they illustrated it is they're trying to  pick up a girl at a bar and there's  multiple girls they're like friend it's  like a friend group and you're trying to  approach i don't remember the details  but i remember don't you like then speak  to her friends yeah something like that  fame disinterest i mean it's classic  pickup artist stuff right you you wanna  and they were trying to uh correlate  that somehow that being an optimal  strategy  a  game theoretically why  why what like i don't think i remember  don't imagine that i mean there's  probably an optimal strategy is it does  that mean that there's an actual nash  equilibrium of like picking up girls  you